يطلق عليه اسم الحرب الباردة في مجال التكنولوجيا ، حيث
يضع البيت الأبيض في القائمة السوداء
ثاني أكبر صانع للهواتف الذكية في
العالم.
الحرب مع الصين التي
تمنع Huawei من شراء أو ترخيص
أجزاء أمريكية ذات تأثيرات مضاعفة من
خلال سلاسل التوريد العالمية
لم يعد بإمكان صانعي الرقائق الأمريكيين بيعها
للصينيين دون تراخيص الحكومة الأمريكية.
الأمن القومي
تقول الصين إنها ضحية لنا
البلطجة الآن أصدرت وزارة التجارة
إعفاءات محدودة لمنتجات هواوي
ولكن الاستراتيجية الصارمة الجديدة
لمواجهة الصين لا تزال سارية
بشكل عام
ولكن ناسداك لا يزال هذا العام
مبلغًا مثيرًا للإعجاب وحتى مع التعريفات الجمركية
والتعريفات المضادة ، لا يزال ناسداك
أعلى مما كان عليه عندما  بدأت الحرب التجارية
في الصيف الماضي كدليل على
مرونة الأسهم وفي نفس
الوقت تذكيرًا بالمخاطر التي تهدد
الجانب السلبي ، يريد الرئيس ترامب من الصين
أن تلعب دورًا عادلًا ، فهو يريد من الصين التوقف عن
سرقة الملكية الفكرية من
الشركات الأمريكية ودعمها بشكل غير عادل.
الصناعات الاستراتيجية
ولديه نفوذ أكبر لاستخدام البيت الأبيض في
إعداد المزيد من التعريفات الجمركية
التي تؤثر على المنتجات الأمريكية المصنوعة في
الصين على كل شيء من أجهزة iPhone إلى
الأحذية الرياضية